[موسيقى]
اعداد مليونيه من المعتمرين والمصلين
يستقبلها المسجد الحرام بعد ان اعلنت
رئاسه شؤون الحرمين ان تشغيل الحرم المكي
بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه دون قيود طوال
شهر رمضان ويقابلها منظومه عمل موسع
[موسيقى]
هناك خطه مشتركه ابواب محدده لدخول المصلي
وابواب محدده لدخول المعتمر حتى يتم خروجه
من هذه الشعيره تقوم الرئاسه بما لديها من
مكونات ومن مستهدفات في خطتها بعرض جميع
محاور هذه الخطه حتى يقوم قاصد بيت الله
الحرام باداء نسخه بكل بكل يسر وسهوله
وبكل طمانينه خصصت رئاسه الشؤون الحرمين
اثني عشر الف موظف وعامل بالمسجد الحرام
وهيات اربعه عشر مسارا خاصا لدخول وخروج
المعتمرين والمصلين الى جانب فتح كافه
التوسعات السعوديه الثلاث بالحرم المكي
وتوفير تسعه الاف عربه كهربائيه ومتحركه
للتسهيل على كبار السن وذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه اضافه الى تسخير التقنيات والذكاء
الاصطناعي رحله المعتمد ورحله
اكتملت جميع خدماته بمنظوماتها التكامليه
والارشاديه وغيرها بالتنسيق مع الجهات
الامنيه فيما يحقق الراحه لقاصدي بيت الله
الحرام تسعى الرئاسه من خلالك وديرها
البشريه المتفانيه بالخبرات التراكميه الى
وضع خطه تشغيليه مرنه لموسم رمضان هذا
العام مع الاخذ في الاعتبار لعوده اعداد
المعتمرين والمصلين الى ما قبل جائحه
فيروس كورونا من الحرم المكي سلطان السلمي
العربيه
[موسيقى]